Hey you. Are you interested in expanding
your horizons in reading a new genre?
Fortunately for you, you've come to the
right place.
I'm on the
frisky.
[Music]
Hi. Hello. I hope you're taking care of
yourself. If you're new here, my name is
Lexi and I read a pretty wide variety of
different books. One thing about being a
mood reader is that you constantly have
to make it everybody else's problem. And
my variety of mood reading is that
typically, unless I'm doing some kind of
vlog where I read books from a
particular genre, I tend to follow up
whatever book I've just finished with
something that is as different as
humanly possible. I have found that that
just makes it easier for me to remember
everything I read as like a distinct
entity. when you're reading a romance
novel that's really cute and sweet and
you follow it up with like a litfic book
about cannibalism, one of those things
is not like the other, they're just
they're easier to remember for me that
way. So that's kind of why I am the way
that I am. And also the things that I
like about books tend to be pretty
independent of genre. I like things like
strong characters, plots that subvert my
expectations and oftentimes subvert
whatever genre the book is supposed to
be. I like books that have themes that
make me think at least three thoughts
about the world around me. I like a
heist. I like a dark, rainy city. I like
books that make me extremely upset. And
the beauty of literature is that you can
really find those things in books of any
genre and also find things that are
better than you could have possibly
imagined just by branching out. And
that's what this video is supposed to
be, I think, because I read a lot of
different things. I get a lot of
questions about doing videos on specific
genres. And the truth is, I mean, I'm
just I'm not an expert, I don't think,
in anything. That's one thing that you
sacrifice when you read the way that I
read. I don't feel like I have a massive
depth of knowledge for any particular
genres, but one thing that I am really
good at is getting my friends and family
to try something new and to dip their
toes into a genre that they might not
have explored before. So that's what
this video is. For almost every single
type of book that I read, I've picked
out like one to four different
recommendations for different kinds of
people who are thinking of trying out
that genre. And a lot of these books are
going to be some of my favorites, but
more so I'm trying to pick out things I
feel like are representative of my
experiences with that genre. So that way
if you pick up one of these books and
you absolutely love it, you know that
there's more like that waiting for you
inside of that genre. And like what the
[__] do I know about science fiction?
What do I know about short story
collections? Probably next to nothing,
but also probably more than you if
you've never read anything from either
of those genres. So that's kind of the
target audience for this video. And
yeah, I mean hopefully this is helpful
to to some of you guys. I really would
encourage you to step outside of your
comfort zone every once in a while when
it comes to books. I feel like the the
only rule that really matters when it
comes to reading as an adult is that you
should read things that you are
interested in reading. But don't
underestimate how many books there might
be out there, even in genres that you
might have written off since high
school, that could really, really hit
for you and be meaningful. Because a
good story is a good story and
everything inside of this video, these
are all good stories in my opinion. But
before we actually get started, I just
have a quick word from the sponsor of
today's video, which is Blueland. If you
are ever overwhelmed, as I often am,
with all of the things that you feel
like you should be doing to try to
counteract how unavoidably destructive
to the environment, just like existing
as a person in the 21st century is, one
easy step that I would recommend is
starting to think about how to make the
things that you already do and the
products that you already use a little
bit more sustainable. And considering
the fact that you are probably already
washing dishes and clothes, maybe even
your hands if we're lucky, seeking out
cleaning products that are just a little
bit more sustainable is one easy thing
that you can do. And that is why I'm so
excited to be partnering again with
Blueland. I have worked with Blueland in
the past and I've been using their hand
soaps and their dishwashing tablets ever
since. The dishwashing tablets
especially are super nice and they're
just as easy as pods. You just you put
them in and you roll and it cleans your
dishes. But this time, I also had the
opportunity to try their laundry and
toilet tablets. And the laundry tablets
are super easy. I got the unscented
variety because I cannot stand it when
my laundry smells like things other than
just water and laundry. But you just
drop them into the drum of your washing
machine before you load anything in. You
can do just one if you have a normal
load, but you can also do two if things
are getting weird and you have a lot of
clothes. And you run it as normal and it
cleans your clothes. The toilet tablets
are also cool. You drop them in, you
wait for them to fizz. I'm like speeding
up this footage right now. They're
bigger than you would expect. So,
honestly, it's kind of surprising that
they dissolve as quickly as you do, but
once they stop, you then swipe at the
bowl with whatever brush that you have.
You flush and then you're done. All of
the Bluelin products that I've tried
have been pretty foolproof in this way.
But all of these all of these products
are purposefully made to avoid as many
harmful ingredients as possible. And
they also arrive at your door without
any single-use plastic in any component,
including shipping. Like everything that
they come with and in is completely
recyclable. So, if you're interested in
checking them out, I would strongly,
strongly recommend either clicking the
link in my description or scanning this
QR code that is right over here and you
can get your first purchase for 15% off.
Thank you so much to Bluelands for
sponsoring this video. I really
appreciate it. Let's get back to it.
Okay, welcome back. I hope that you
stayed safe out there during my ad. The
first genre that we will be exploring
together in this beginner's guide is
fantasy. And fantasy is by definition an
extremely large, imaginative, and
diverse space. I feel like from an
outside perspective, what you might
think about when you think about fantasy
is the quintessential like white dude
bro medieval Western Europe fantasy
novels. And I don't mean to like slander
any of those books at all. That's not
the intention of me saying that. But I
feel like Game of Thrones kind of
created that vibe inside of the cultural
consciousness as to what fantasy is. But
the truth is the genre has so many
different things to offer and that is
only one portion. And in an effort to
highlight a lot of the ways that fantasy
as a genre can be really unique, all of
these recommendations are from kind of
different corners of the fantasy world.
The first recommendation I have is for
people who are interested in getting
into fantasy by way of reading a lot of
contemporary or literary fiction. I
would recommend that you pick up Pureazy
by Susanna Clark. I also think that this
book could be good for anybody who loves
mysteries and suspense, although maybe
not like the type of thriller where it's
just a ton of crazy [__] happening one
after another. That is not the vibe of
this book, but it does feel the entire
time kind of like a puzzle box that
you're taking apart. The premise of this
very briefly, this book follows a guy
named Pyreazy who lives inside of this
gigantic endless mansion. The mansion is
magical. It has many secrets. It seems
to be basically infinite. And Pyrees has
dedicated basically his entire life to
exploring and mapping out this mansion.
And the overwhelming majority of the
time, Pureazy is doing all of this alone
in solitude. But once or twice every
week, this guy named the other comes in
and they talk about their experiences
and Pyrees tries to help him with this
thing that he's working on. But that's
it. That's the only other person that
Pyreazy has ever seen inside of this
house until he ends up discovering
evidence of some other mysterious
person. The pros inside of this book is
definitely quite literary, especially
for a fantasy novel where like with any
fantasy novel, you're kind of trying to
like understand a lot of the various
locations and names for things that
Pyreazy has. fantasy typically requires
you to kind of download a new
vocabulary, and this book kind of does
do that, but in a way where he's still
using plain English, so it's still
accessible. It's just it's kind of
dense. I loved this book. I feel like
it's one of the most unique, especially
standalones that I've read in the
fantasy genre. And if in general you
like books that even though they're
short, they're still rich with meaning
and they like beg you to really take
your time with them, that's what this
is. It's pretty experimental. It's
beautifully descriptive. It's a really
neat character study into what makes
this guy tick. And the experience of
unraveling the mystery at the center of
this book is super satisfying. Okay,
next up, if you're coming into fantasy
by way of being a romance reader, I
would recommend you one of two things.
One of them with more of my full chest
than the other one, but I'm going to
give you both. The first book I would
recommend is The Serpent and the Wings
of Night. This is a standard issue Tik
Tok romanty down to the fact that there
are trials that they do. There's a
competition that the main character, who
is a feral, knife wielding bdie,
participates in across from a man who is
kind of brooding and mysterious. It has
a lot of those really big tropes that
are popular right now. I don't think
this book is perfect by any means, but
if you're somebody who typically reads a
lot of like really indulgent romances,
but you've always found fantasy to be
kind of intimidating, I just think that
this is a great place to start because
the book does make effort to do world
building and to do things like having
political minations that are happening
in the background, different allegiances
that the protagonists have to decide
between. And I think that if you are a
romance reader, you might be surprised
by not only how easy it is to understand
those parts of the story, but also by
how much you might enjoy them. and that
can then give you the willpower and the
motivation to tackle some more complex
worlds down the road. But I mean, not
everything even has to be that complex.
Mostly the purpose of this book on this
list is to prove to you that fantasy can
also be fun. It can be indulgent, it can
be kind of silly. That's what this was
for me. Even with the flaws that I do
feel like it had, but on the other hand,
if you are a romance reader who wants to
try something that has a little bit
stronger fantasy elements and fantasy
theming, but still retaining a strong
romantic subplot at the center of the
story, I would recommend One Dark
Window. This to me represents a type of
fantasy that reads a lot more similarly
to like adult fairy tales. It's
atmospheric. It's whimsical. It has a
very classical trope at the center of it
in terms of the main character has a
darkness inside of her that is kind of
possessing her. They have a really weird
relationship where like technically he's
a curse, but also he kind of protects
her whenever she's in danger. And if
anybody inside of her kingdom found out
that she was harboring this dark shadow
spirit, she would be like killed on
site. So, in an effort to maintain this
secret, she kind of gets blackmailed
into helping this guy whose name is
Raven with a Y, she goes on a quest with
Raven with a Y to collect what is
essentially just a deck of magical tarot
cards that if they get all of them,
they'll be able to save the kingdom,
among other things. The book is mostly
the quest that they're going on and
their relationships with their family,
with the kingdom, etc. There's a lot of
[__] drama inside of everybody's
backstory, but it's also it definitely
does still have a pretty strong romance
at the center of the story both in this
book and then also in the second book in
the series. It's a duogy. And I think
that this is just a good entry point.
It's not too complicated, but also still
the world feels complex. It feels
complete. So, it's not intimidating and
it still has a romance to kind of sink
your teeth into. But the main thing I
liked about these books was the plot. It
was the fantasy of it all. So, it's a
good entry point in that way. Next up,
if you want something that is
classically young adult, like if you
read a lot of YA growing up and then you
kind of stopped and never got back into
it, and you want a young adult fantasy
story, but you also want a young adult
fantasy story, that is way better than
you probably remember the young adult
fantasy stories being when you were a
kid, I got T-Rex for that again. We have
Legendb Born and then I have Ray Bearer.
And the Legendb Born series is ongoing.
It's not complete. We're still waiting
on the last book, but this one is a
duogy and both books are out. Ray Bear
is about a society where once the prince
of the kingdom comes of age, he chooses
this like council of extremely trusted
peers. And once the council is complete,
everybody inside of that council is
basically immortal. Like they can't be
killed except by the other people inside
of the council. Hence why trusting those
people that you use to magically
ascertain your own immortality is pretty
important. And the book follows a girl
who has been raised since childhood to
infiltrate the prince's circles, join
this council, and ultimately assassinate
him. Legendb Born, in contrast, is a
pretty different story. This one is an
urban fantasy that's set at UNC Chapel
Hill, and it follows a girl named Bri,
who ends up discovering and also kind of
infiltrating this secret society that is
based around the mythology of the
Knights of King Arthur. And most of the
members of this secret society have
dedicated their lives to fighting in
this like demon war that has been
ongoing. But Bri is hellbent on joining
because she is pretty sure that this
society might have had something to do
with the recent death of her mother,
which was very mysterious. So much
occurs in both of these books. Neither
of those summaries really scratch the
surface of what these are. But what I
like most about these, and one of the
big reasons why I still read young adult
fantasy, is they really subvert your
expectations as a reader. They both just
strike this incredible balance of being
simultaneously really nostalgic, but
also fresh. And if you've been on like a
10 to 15ear sbatical from reading
fantasy, if you haven't read anything in
the genre since you were a teenager, I
think that both of these will really hit
for you and remind you why you love it.
These two series are some of my favorite
things that have been published over the
course of the last few years, so you're
in for a treat. Last fantasy book before
we finally move on to other things. If
you are confident in your ability to
immerse yourself into a complicated
world, you're willing to do the work of
getting through that first 50 to 75
pages where everything kind of feels
like gibberish, and you really just want
to start off your fantasy journey in the
deep end, experiencing, in my opinion,
one of the greatest fantasy stories that
the genre has to offer. I would pick up
The Fifth Season by NK Gemson. And I
debated whether or not to include this
in this list because it is definitely
more narratively ambitious than the
other books we've talked about so far
that give you a little bit more of an
on-ramp. But ultimately, the reason why
it's still here is this was actually one
of my first big adult epic fantasy
reads. And I feel like for me, one of
the best ways to fall in love with a new
genre was to read something that was
truly singular. And that's what this is.
This book is about a world where all of
society has been built up around the
idea of doomsday prepping because they
just have these like insane natural
disasters all of the time. And within
this society, there are a group of
people that are basically able to
earthbend. It's more complicated than
that, but that's probably the easiest
way of thinking about it. But because
they have magical powers including
terraforming and and the world is facing
these constant apocalyptic events, all
of these earthbenders are living in this
constant state of fear because either
they join the government basically and
do state sanctioned labor or
alternatively if they try to stay in
hiding so they don't have to do that,
their villages will like kill them on
site as soon as they find out that
they're earthbenders. So it's not a
great time. And the book starts off with
what it tells you is the last ever
apocalyptic event, the apocalypse to end
all apocalypses. and it follows these
three different women who are navigating
just everything that is going on inside
of this world without even approaching
like a two-mile radius around spoiler
territory. This is one of the coolest
books I've ever read. What this book is
able to accomplish, I think about all
the time. It's a full trilogy. There are
three books and they're all fantastic,
but especially this first book really
shows you how expertly it is possible to
build out a world and to build out a
story when you are a master storyteller
as NKGeem absolutely is. And if you are
willing to dive into the deep end, if
you are willing to, again, especially if
you're new to fantasy, not really know
what the [__] is going on for a
substantial part of this book, probably
until like page 75, the journey is so
worth it. This is definitely the book
that made me love epic fantasy. Next up
is science fiction. And I only have one
wreck for this. In part because I'm a
bit of an amateur, honestly, with
science fiction, but also I have
personally recommended this book to like
four people in my life, and they've all
really liked it. This is one of my most
successful recommendations. I think it
is a wonderful introduction into the
genre. This is Project Hail Mary by Andy
Weir. If you like movies, especially all
of the space movies, you probably saw
The Martian when it came out, God, maybe
five or six years ago. That movie was
adapted from a book by the same author.
And I think that if you liked that
movie, you will like this book. But I
read that book. I watched that movie.
And I love this book a lot more than
either of those two things. So don't
just strike it out if you didn't like
The Martian. Project Hail Mary is about
a guy who wakes up on a spaceship
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
whatever miles from home and he quickly
discovers that he is the only person on
his mission that actually survived being
in like cryostasis the entire time that
he was traveling. He's the only guy who
made it, which is already pretty
unfortunate. But what is double
unfortunate is that he wakes up with no
memories of what the [__] the mission is
actually even supposed to be. He doesn't
even know who he is. It's full amnesia
from the minute that he steps out of his
cryochamber. And the only thing that he
can really figure out right away is that
the mission that he's on is extremely
important. It's like life or death for
Earth. But he doesn't even know what the
mission is, much less what he's supposed
to be doing for it. And as he's trying
to figure all of this out before he runs
out of supplies, a bunch of interesting
things happen from there, which I know
doesn't give you a lot, but I really
feel like this book is best enjoyed
knowing as little about it as possible.
Trying to think of like how to capture
how this book makes you feel. If you
like sports, if you like rooting for
teams, if you've ever been way too into
chess or esports or like survivor or
something, this book will rock your
world. It's the kind of book that has
you punching air. It makes you feel like
you could fight God by the time that you
get to the last chapter. And I also feel
like it's a great introduction into the
more technical parts of science fiction
without also being way too intimidating
and like drowning you in data and facts
and science. There is data. There are
facts. There is science inside of this
book, but it's all accessible. It all
feels like you can actually chew on it,
no matter what your background is. And
it's woven into the story really, really
well. Read if you like space, read if
you like interstellar, if you like
stories about human willpower, you'll
have a great time. Next up is if you are
considering reading a memoir, but
especially if you're like me and you
could not give less of a [__] about 99%
celebrities. If you are an absolute
beginner and all that you know for sure
is that you have an unquenchable thirst
for drama that does not involve you, I
would recommend that you pick up Maybe
You Should Talk to Someone. This is a
memoir that is by a therapist and the
memoir follows at the same time her
experiences with her own practice being
a therapist and giving therapy to a
variety of different people but also her
experience going to therapy herself and
dealing with a variety of different
problems that she has in her personal
life. You know, tag yourself if you
relate to this statement, I guess. But I
feel like there's just something about
being mentally ill that makes you a
funnier person for everything bad that
it does. I feel like it just it makes
you have better jokes. And I think this
book captures really well the dichconomy
of like simultaneously having real
problems that suck and that are serious,
but it's also funny and her clients are
funny and a lot of what they're dealing
with even when it's extremely serious.
You can cope with it by being kind of
funny. This book most of the time isn't
laugh out loud hilarious or anything. I
mean like almost no books are like that
for me, but it is extremely charming. I
love the writing style. I love the way
that she knits together everybody's
stories. I remember when I was reading
this book, I was like, "Where is Hippa?
What's going on?" But I mean, she
definitely had to get permission from
everybody who she even kind of covered
inside of here. So, you don't have to
worry about that. But, it's compulsively
readable. It's a great book for nosy
[__] It's just like tea front to
back about the lives of people who
you'll never meet. But, it also really
sneaks up on you with how meaningful it
ends up being by the end. Just the way
that the author brings everything
together with her own experiences as
well. It's just it's it's the kind of
book that makes you want to go to
therapy and talk about your problems
with people, which I would say is a
pretty good thing for most people to
want to do. It's a pretty good result to
come from a book. So, would recommend.
Next up, this is not a beginner pick,
but if you're coming into reading a
memoir from reading a lot of
experimental fiction, whether that's
literary fiction or horror or something
else, if you're like really into art
house scary movies, I would strongly
strongly recommend you try In the
Dreamhouse. This is one of my favorite
books of all time, actually. It's so
good. It's so good. It's so good. It's
so good. This is about a woman who finds
herself in an abusive relationship and
the book is broken up into these like
extremely short chapters that are
explorations, not chronologically, of
her story through the lens of a bunch of
different horror tropes and horror
trends. And it's basically a whole 250
page book of flash fiction about her
experiences. Sometimes, depending on the
chapter, it can bridge into being a
little bit closer to cultural criticism.
But the entire book is just a reckoning
of what abuse can do to a person and
also of how you recover from that
because you also get to see snapshots of
her future extremely healthy
relationship with her wife down the
road. I also really appreciate how this
book spotlights abuse that can also
happen inside of queer relationships
because I mean, as a society, we already
barely talk about abusive relationships,
but that is especially true within the
queer community. And I love how this
book deals with the implications of
that. But if you like experimental
things in other genres, if you like
books that play with form and play with
your expectations in really interesting
ways, In the Dreamhouse is that girl,
this is the memoir that you should pick
up because it really pushes the
boundaries of what you think a memoir
can be. Okay, next up, if you want
something a little bit faster paced and
maybe you're coming from non-fiction,
you want something with a bit more of a
journalistic bent, this book is also
good if you're coming from predominantly
reading thrillers or like suspense
novels. I would hardly recommend Into
Thin Air. This book is about the Everest
disaster from 1996 where a bunch of
different people died from different
expeditions who were trying to summit
Mount Everest. Literally something, by
the way, that I just I have no interest
doing. I I don't think we were meant to
go up that high. It's none of my
business what's up there. But a bunch of
people tried to go see the sites and a
combination of extremely bad weather and
also incompetence from the people who
were leading the expedition and also
just like random sincere tragedy. All of
that led to just an absolute freak show
where even the people who did not die
were just like traumatized for the rest
of their lives or like they lost arms or
fingers or something to frostbite. And
unfortunately for him, but also
fortunately for us as consumers, John
Crockower, who was mostly just a
journalist at the time, I feel like this
was way before his novels were as big as
they are now. He was on one of these
expeditions. He was doing it for like
Outside magazine, so he just happened to
be there when all of this insane [__]
was happening. So, it's a firsthand
account from his perspective of that
entire experience, but also in addition
to that, because he's a journalist, the
book digs into the backgrounds of
everybody else who was on those
expeditions in an effort to find out why
this happened, how everything could have
possibly gone so wrong. So, it ends up
kind of reading as this like hybrid of
journalistic non-fiction, memoir,
suspense, thriller. You put all of that
[__] in a blender and also add in a real
thing that is like really sad that
happened. Boom, you get into thin air.
Great book. If you've ever wanted to do
something like this, I I can promise you
that you will not want to anymore after
you finish it. The final memoir I will
be recommending to you is if you do have
any interest at all in celebrities, but
also just to anybody who wants to read a
little bit more of a typical memoir.
Like this is what I was like as a kid.
This is how these experiences impacted
me growing up. Now I'm a teenager. Oh
boy, now I'm an adult and I'm dealing
with like the weight of all of the
consequences of every decision that
everybody in my life has ever made. I
would pick up Born a Crime by Trevor
Noah. Trevor Noah grew up in South
Africa during like the last days of
apartheid. And the memoir in general,
even though it does have kind of an
anecdotal vibe to it, it's a bunch of
snapshots from his childhood, his
teenage years, his young adulthood, it
still feels a little bit more than the
other things I've recommended to you so
far, like a typical this is the story of
my life as opposed to what I've been
talking about where those are books that
are about discreet events. This book is
also pretty funny sometimes. It's pretty
good at dealing with that full spectrum
of human emotion because Trevor Noah
went through a lot of [__] in his
childhood. Like there are some serious
things that he explores in this book,
but the tone of the book just brackets
all of those events with such a good
sense of humor and just like in a
reverence in the way that he sees the
world. I also like this book because
unless he has the most competent ghost
writer the world has ever seen, it
really feels like you can tell that he
wrote it, which is not the case for
every celebrity memoir. And yeah, I mean
there are a couple of other good ones
that I'll throw on screen that also get
my celebrity memoir stamp of approval,
but I think that long term this has been
my favorite. Okay, next up we have
contemporary and literary fiction. And
for those of you who might not know what
the difference between those two genres
is, let me tell you, or at least let me
give you like my understanding and how I
use these terms. They are usually
shelves together under fiction or
general fiction at the bookstore. In
both cases, you're going to have stories
that are largely happening during the
present day. But where contemporary
fiction books are going to be faster
paced, they're going to be more plot-
driven, there's probably a little bit
less of a focus on things like
atmosphere and descriptive writing in
favor of things like dialogue that move
the plot forward. Whereas literary
fiction is character-driven. It's
slowpaced. These are the kinds of books
where you just you sit in the head for
350 pages of a guy who is like
unspooling every single trauma that he's
ever experienced while amling the
streets of New York City looking to like
meet women at bars. But none of them can
fill up the void that was left behind by
his mother who abandoned him when he was
a child and left behind only like a
collection of [__] sonnetss by
Shakespeare or something. Ballic also
typically in being slower paced, it's a
lot more atmospheric. It's really
interested in giving you a sense of
place, a sense of time, a sense of like
how your character is interacting with
those things. And a lot of the books
that ultimately become classics are
litfic because again, you're capturing
that sense of what it was actually like
to be a part of history when it was
happening. But yeah, at the core of it,
you can really think of it as is this
book plot- driven or is this book
character driven? Is this book
interested in keeping up a brisk pace
and having a lot of interesting things
happen or is this book interested in
like languishing in those moments and
really making you reflect with the
characters as they grow and develop on
complicated and evolving themes.
However, like with any binary, there are
also so many books that fall somewhere
in between those two extremes where it
can be kind of difficult to determine
what bucket to put them in. Pretty much
every book that you read will have at
least some interest in both developing
its characters and having like something
like an a plot like an interesting thing
happening. So when you get to the middle
of the spectrum, it can be it can be
kind of wonky. It's really a vibe thing.
Honestly, I think that for everybody
it's mostly a vibe thing, but like the
difference is not that serious. It's
just it's useful to you when I'm doing a
wrap-up or something and I label
something as lithic to kind of get you
get an idea of the reading experience of
that book, right? But hopefully knowing
a little bit more about the distinction
is helpful to you if you ever hear
people talking about them like they're
different things because they kind of
are. They they are, but they're also
ultimately both just general adult
fiction. But anyways, in that vein, if
you are looking for contemporary adult
fiction, I would recommend Frederick
Bachman. Really, anything by Frederick
Bachman, but the two books I'm going to
talk about are A Man Called UVA and then
Beartown. And this is maybe the first
dagger in the entire treatise I just did
about what the difference between litfic
and contemporary fiction is because
Frederick Bachmann is super interested
in exploring his characters especially
in this book. You could argue that this
book is just a character study of UVA.
But man, this is just this is what I
mean because these books don't have
litfig vibes. Like they are solidly
contemporary fiction to me and I love
these two books. I think they're both
fantastic. Frederick is Swedish so all
of his books are in translation and they
also all happen in Sweden. A man Called
Uba is about a really grumpy old man who
kind of like hates himself and his life
and also everybody around him all of the
time, but his whole routine and
existence kind of gets shaken up when a
new family arrives and moves in across
the street from him. And Beartown,
meanwhile, has a much much larger cast
and it follows a bunch of different
residents inside of this town where
really the only thing to do is either
play hockey in high school or like watch
those high schoolers play hockey. And so
the entire town revolves around the
performance of the high school hockey
team. And Beartown's team has been
really [__] bad for a really long
time until finally this season, it seems
like they might have a real chance to go
pretty far into nationals. But then
something really bad happens and it
divides the entire town. And the book
kind of explores how well you really
know the people who are around you, how
well you know your neighbors, the power
of a community both to like heal and
also to harm, and just really what makes
a good person. Like those are the
questions that Frederick Bachmann is
interested in investigating both in this
book and also really in all of his
books. He has a very didactic writing
style that you will either absolutely
love or absolutely [__] hate where it
could maybe be patronizing if you're the
wrong kind of reader for his books
because this man loves amusing. He loves
a wisdom that he shares with you through
some kind of like beautiful sentence
that even in its simplicity astounds you
with how true to life it actually is.
And I just love his books. I feel like
he's a great entry point if you want to
start reading adult contemporary fiction
but you like are scared it's going to be
boring or something. These are not
boring and they will also make you
reflect on the human condition in the
way that all of the best fiction novels
do. Next up for litfic, if you are an
absolute beginner and also if you didn't
like the classics that you read in high
school but you're willing to try
something in that style again now that
you're an adult, now that you might be
like a little bit more patient, I would
start with Writers and Lovers by Lily
King. This is not my favorite litfic
book that I've ever read. Honestly, it
might not even be in my top five even
though I did like it. But it is at the
perfect intersection of both being
incredibly accessible even for people
who haven't read lipfic before and also
still being I think pretty demonstrative
of the types of books that you will
often see within the genre which
honestly similar to fantasy obviously
there there's like such a wealth of
different things that you can do with
litfic but stylistically I think that
whether you enjoy this book or not
whether you find it boring or not how
you feel about the way that the story is
told I think would be a really good
barometer for how you might feel about
most modern literary fiction. This book
follows a girl whose name, honestly, I
forget. What is it? Casey. It follows a
girl named Casey who is this struggling
writer who's living out in the American
Northeast, and she's kind of a [__]
She's anxious. She's really low morale,
but she's like trying to get back on to
that self-improvement grind. And at the
same time, she is juggling these two
relationships with these two different
men in her life who also both kind of
suck, but in different ways. The book is
super slice of life. The pros is
beautiful. Like it's really well done
and it captures that litfic vibe of like
these are the deepest darkest thoughts
and feelings that you've ever had in
your entire life but you've been too
embarrassed to share and they're on page
and now you have to like look at that
and deal with them. Isn't that crazy?
Okay, next up because I'm not doing like
a full category for historical fiction
considering the fact that I feel like I
know [__] nothing about historical
fiction. This is a novel that is written
in a very litfic style, but it's also
historical fiction. And more than that,
it's like a generational family saga,
which is something that you see a lot of
in historical fiction. And if you are
interested in trying your hand at
something like that, I would recommend
Homegoing by Yagyazi. You have these two
halfsisters who are born in Ghana during
the 18th century, but they don't know
that the other person exists because
they're born in different villages with
like completely different circumstances.
And one of these sisters will marry a
white guy from England and therefore
live a life of especially compared to
most of her community relative luxury.
But the other sister will be captured
and enslaved. And it follows not only
both of these original sisters but also
like six or seven generations of their
family down to the modern day. The book
is super ambitious. You're basically
reading 10 to 14 somewhere in that range
different noavellas about these
different characters at different points
in history who are also kind of still
connected even with all of this distance
between them. Fabulous, stunning, and
also compares well to writers and lovers
because these are two very different
things that you can do with a similar
kind of like introspective meditative
style in your pros. Okay, next up, if
you're coming into reading literary
fiction via reading a lot of romance, I
would recommend picking up The Song of
Achilles if you have not already. This
book obviously, and for reasons that
still surprise me, went mega viral on
Tik Tok, but in my opinion, it
completely deserved it. I [__] love
this book. I also love Cersei, Maline
Miller's other book, but this is a
retelling of the Iliad from the
perspective of Patrick Cliss and also
taking like a lot of different creative
liberties to really flesh out the story
of everything that happens. But one
creative liberty that this book does not
take is its acknowledgement that the
Iliad was pretty [__] gay and that
the story of Achilles in Patrick was
kind of fruity. It was it was a little
bit fruity. You will never hear anybody
describe this book as a romance novel.
And if you did, like I would look at you
funny because it's not, but it is at its
core very, very much a love story. The
pace of this book is slow. Once again,
it's a character study both of Patrick
Liss, but also of Achilles. The writing
in this book is absolutely [__]
gorgeous. Like, it's pros that you could
swim in. And if you are a romance
reader, if you just really, really need
a strong central love story to justify
trying out a new genre, this is it for
you. This is one of my favorite love
stories in literature. like point blank
period. Okay, I'm going to try to speed
up because I would like to finish this
video before the sun sets and I have to
move and I've been rambling for way
longer than I anticipated rambling for.
Story of my life. But if you are
interested in getting into essay
collections, I love essay collections. I
feel like it feeds the part of my
personality that wishes I read a lot
more featurelength news articles because
a lot of the time, unless it's a more
personal essay collection, those
definitely exist, too. That's kind of
what they are. They're like 6 to 12
different featurelength articles by an
author exploring a variety of different
cultural or social phenomena. I really
like essay collections because it makes
reading, especially non-fiction, a lot
easier to fit into your life when you're
really only committing to one 15 to 30
page story at a time. And if you are
interested in picking one up, I have one
recommendation for you. It is The
Anthroposine Reviewed by John Green.
John Green was a very important part of
my formative years on this planet. I was
a big crash course girly. I read like
every single book that he had released
up until maybe I was 16 or so. And
especially given the fact that I feel
like a lot of his young adult novels
have not exactly aged perfectly well. I
can definitively say that this book is
my favorite thing that he has ever put
into this world. Even accounting for
nostalgia. The gimmick of this
collection is that John Green takes a
bunch of random [__] like
Velociraptors and Academic Decathlon,
the Indianapolis 500 and Monopoly, and
he is writing essays that are kind of
about that thing. Some of them are more
about that thing than others, but he
connects it in some way to the human
condition and to like the beauty and
tragedy of being alive on this planet.
And then at the end of the essay, he
gives it a rating between one and five
stars. I love this collection. To me,
it's just a reminder of all of those
little things that you have in your life
that make it worthwhile to continue
amling forward even when you're confused
and things are bad, which is very John
Green of him to make the theme of his
book. And I think it's a good starting
point because a lot of it is personal.
It's poignant. It's almost like memoir
style pieces, but you do still have
pieces that have more of a research
basis that have a little bit more
cultural criticism going on inside of
them as well. Okay, next up, in the vein
of short, bite-sized, easy to fit into
your life, if you would like to start
reading a short story collection, but
you have no idea where to start, and you
want something that is mostly
straightforward, but also still high
quality, I would pick up Anything by
Danielle Evans, and I say anything, but
I'm pretty sure she just has these two
books of short stories. Those of you who
are like absolute OGs, I think the only
other time I've talked about this book
on my channel was the first video I ever
made. But this is The Office of
Historical Corrections, this is to this
day one of my favorite books of all
time. But it's also kind of hard to
recommend sometimes because it's a short
story collection. There's no singular
cohesive narrative. It's a book full of
cohesive and interesting narratives. But
I also liked her first collection,
Before You Suffocate Your Own Full Self.
This is also good. Danielle Evans writes
stories that are at the intersection of
race and gender and class. And her books
normally feature women who are at some
kind of crossroads. They have some kind
of really difficult decision that
they're going to have to make. And in
lie of actually telling you anything
about what these stories are about
because honestly I want you to like dude
just trust me because this book is just
it's so [__] good. If you have any
interest at all in reading a short story
collection, you should pick this one.
You should try this one. But I'm going
to read you like two quotes without any
context at all that I feel like are
extremely relevant to the current moment
in this country. At that the crowd
joined in. This was one of the free
Americans rallying cries. We are the
future. A cheerful way of saying the
shame of the US past wasn't genocide or
terror, but the fact that it hadn't
completely worked yet. It was nothing I
hadn't heard before, but it was
rattling. It was the ubiquity, or it was
the persistence. It was the way the free
Americans and their claims on being the
only Americans transcended facts and
time and progress. The way they always
seem to be around the corner. The way,
however lacking in general insight they
might be, they could somehow hear the
ticking clock of the question. the do
they know I'm human yet. The way they
took delight in saying no. The way they
took for granted that it would always be
their question to answer. And this one
is less political, but I think it's
still really good. All of her adult
life, people have asked Reena why she
goes to such dangerous places. And she
has always wanted to ask them where the
safe place is. The danger is in
chemicals and airports and refugee camps
and war zones and regions known for sex
tourism. The danger also sometimes took
their trash out for them. The danger
came over for movie nights and brought
them a popcorn maker for Christmas. the
danger hugged her mother and shook her
father's hand. You should just you
should check this book out. It's really
good. The other wreck I will give you I
didn't even pull because I lost this
book when I was moving and I'm still
bitter about it. The other wreck I will
give you if you've never read short
stories before but you want something
that's like a little bit more
experimental. If you're coming from a
love of horror or a love of literary
fiction, it's the same author as In the
Dreamhouse from earlier. So everything
that I said during that section about
the kind of person who would like that
book, same exact thing. If you're that
person, you will probably also like her
short story collection, Her Body and
Other Parties. Super experimental.
There's a story in there that's just I
think it's every single episode of Law
and Order SVU. Every title of an episode
is a different paragraph inside of the
story. And the story kind of a little
bit is inspired by Law and Order SVU,
but also has completely different
chronology. But the whole collection is
great. Like whether you like or you hate
the pieces, you will want to talk about
them. You will want to discuss them with
people in your life, which again is one
of the marks of worthwhile fiction. So,
strongly recommends that one as well.
But moving on, power rounds. We're going
to try to get through these last two
categories. First, we're going to do
thriller. If you are an absolute
beginner, if you've never read a
thriller novel before, I would pick up
First Lie Wins. I know that the reviews
of this low-key have been a little bit
polarizing since I read it, which
surprises me, but I thought that this
was really good. It's about a con woman
who just lives under a series of fake
identities and she is living longterm as
like the girlfriend of her current
target when they go to a party together
and she meets another woman who it turns
out is living under her actual identity
like the conwoman's original personal
story, her personal history. That's the
person that she meets. She meets
herself, like a pretend version of
herself. Obviously kind of freaky. And
she ends up going on this like wild
goose chase to discover what the [__] is
going on. If you're a beginner, this
book is good because it has the break
neck fast pacing and also kind of
unrealistic twists and turns that you
will see in a lot of thrillers in the
genre. The lack of realism can sometimes
bother me in other books. But in this
one, I honestly just thought it was fun.
It's just a romp. It's a good time. But
if you were coming into reading
thrillers from a more literary
background, if you mostly read classics,
litfic, even contemporary fiction, I
would pick up In My Dreams I Hold a
Knife. This book is about a college
reunion where these six friends who
haven't seen each other for a decade
meet up. And the reason that they
haven't seen each other since then is
because one of their friends was
murdered. Like the seventh person in the
friend group slain. And the
circumstances of that were suspicious. I
think like one of them even went to jail
for it or at least went through the
court system. Honestly, I don't 100%
remember. But the reason why litic
enjoyers will enjoy this book is because
this book is like reading the diary of
the worst person that you have ever met
in your entire life. Bar none. It's
pretty slow among thrillers. The
suspense is really just figuring things
out and seeing how awful these people
can be to each other. Dare I say a
little little little bit, it reminds me
of The Secret History. If instead of
being extremely pretentious and
literary, The Secret History was a true
genre thriller. And to be clear, if it
was a true genre thriller, it would no
longer be The Secret History. So, like,
they're not actually that similar as
books, but I don't know, man. I feel
like you got to catch the vibe. I feel
like there's something there. If you
really really enjoy an unlikable
character, an unreliable set of
narrators, I think that this book might
work for you. Okay, next up, young adult
thrillers. If you're looking for things
that are a little bit less gory than you
will find in an adult thriller and also
that are usually a little bit more of a
true mystery, the first one I would
recommend if you're into criminal minds
or true crime or anything just in that
general vein, I would recommend you
Nunch Shall Sleep. This is a book that
from page one requires you to suspend
your disbelief, but if you can do that,
it's a pretty fun time. It follows a
girl in the 1980s who is the sole
survivor of a serial killer who has
since been incarcerated and the FBI
knocks on her door and they're like,
"Hey, what if you joined a program
because you're like battleh hardened and
you were the sole survivor of a serial
killer. What if you like joined this
program where you interrogated serial
killers?" Because that's totally a thing
that would happen. And specifically to
make this slightly less insane, it's
still insane, but she's interviewing
other teenagers like their juvenile
serial killers. I guess the idea with
this is that they'll be more honest if
it's a person their age. That that is
the idea that the FBI in this world are
working with. But this book is kind of a
mix between Mind Hunter and then also
Silence of the Lambs because the killer
that Emma ends up spending the most time
interviewing is this other teenager
whose name is Simon. And he is like a
hyper competent serial killer
psychopath. Really charming though. and
she's basically using him to consult on
these ongoing cold cases which include
this copycat that he has that looks a
lot like the murders that he committed.
She's talking with him about that in the
interest of figuring out who that person
is so they can then arrest them. What
recommends if you're looking for
something that is fun, kind of like
Criminal Minds, Silence of the Lambs
slasher movie vibes, but also teeny
Bobby. If you want something that is a
little bit more [__] up, I didn't pull
it because to me it's not exactly a
beginner thriller, but I don't know man.
If you want to start off like again off
the deep end, pick up Pretty Girls by
Karen Slaughter. But like don't blame me
for the fact that you decided to go
[__] drown in the ocean instead of
starting on the shore. That book is
[__] up. That book is extremely
intense. Also on the young adult side,
if you want to start off with thrillers
that are thematically still really
intense, you can also find those there.
Even though there's overall less gore,
that does not mean there's overall less
trauma and crime. Sadi is really, really
good and has kind of like a podcasty
thing going on inside of it. And then
also Firekeeper's Daughter is one of my
favorite young adult thrillers. Both
quite serious business in terms of
trigger warnings, but both also really
really good and again like demonstrative
of why I still think there's a lot of
value to be found reading YA. But yeah,
those were your more intense
recommendations if you want to start
with something that is a little bit less
just kind of stupid fun. Okay, last
category and also the only category that
I actually have made a separate video
for. I do have a romance genre video.
So, because of that, I think I actually
talked about four out of these five
books in that video. So, you know what?
I'm actually, dare I say, not going to
synopsize any of these because I already
have pretty recently on this channel.
And also because honestly, I want you
guys to like, dude, just trust me. I'm
going to tell you who I think needs
these books and also who I think you
will become if you read them and you
have your like third eye opens to the
world of romance. Okay, sound good?
Great. If you are coming into romance by
way of litfic or contemporary adult
fiction, I would recommend to you Emily
Henry, especially book lovers or I also
think that you might end up really
liking Beachread. Those are the two that
I feel you're most likely to resonate
with. Emily Henry books in general
always have a strong Bplot. They always
have a fairly strong supporting cast.
They're interested in the characters as
people, even apart from their
relationship. But they are still like
quintessential romance novels. If that
is too normal for you and you would like
something with like 3% more whimsy, a
little bit of magic, a little bit of
fantasy going on, but not enough for it
to really matter, like not enough for it
to not be a romance novel anymore. I
would recommend to you either Half a
Soul or alternatively the very secret
society of a regular witches. Both
extremely beginner friendly. This one
has more of a Regency era writing style
to it, whereas this one is modern. But
they both have magic. They both have
brooding, smartass men inside of them.
They both made me feel like extremely
happy when I read them. Would recommend.
Speaking of feeling happy and wanting to
like seek joy in your dark life, if you
would like to try your hands at a young
adult romance and you love contemporary
teenage romcoms, I would recommend to
you She Gets the Girl, which is a sappic
romcom that I'm also 98% sure is loosely
based off of the actual history of how
the authors met, which I just I really
like that. I find that really cute. And
then finally, if you would like to start
at the top of the mountain and just have
every other romance novel that you ever
read be worse because you've already
experienced the best that the genre has
to offer, I would recommend picking up
Seven Days in June. I glaze the [__] out
of this book [__] all of the time on
this channel. It's fantastic. It's a
masterpiece. It's one of the only books,
almost never do I feel this way, but I
was just talking about this with Eden.
This is one of the only books where if
somebody doesn't like it, I just I
seriously doubt that we have the same
taste in romance. That is how much I
[__] with this book. I will not
entertain a single moat of Seven Days in
June Slander. But if you want more
information on my feelings on the
romance genre in general or on those
books or on probably 10 others that I
also recommend. You can check out that
video. I go a lot more in depth there.
But I still wanted to briefly talk about
my Rex in this video as well, just so
that way we really cover all of the
necessary ground here. But the ground
has been covered. There's no more like
exposed soil. It is just grass as far as
the eye can see. The video is over. You
and I are both free. But thank you guys
for watching. If you have read any of
these books and you liked them, let me
know. If you think I'm like psychotic
for recommending anything as a beginner
book, you can also let me know. And I
would love to hear your recommendations.
If there are any genres that were not
featured in this video that you kind of
expected to see, it was just because I
did not feel like I had the expertise
necessary. And yeah, that's it. We
finally finished filming a video before
I had to turn on the secondary light
source. That's a win. We take the
victories that we can during these
trying times. That's it. I don't have
anything else to say. Bye.